[Music]
a phenomenal journey to win the title of
pirate king Monkey D Luffy and the straw
hat Pirates haven't had it easy evil of
different shapes and colors lurks at
every corner a legion of villains each
more wicked than the other plays a
pivotal role in the growth of our
champion sheer range of characters is
staggering and their mind-blowing
prowess in battle makes watching this
Shonen series that much more exciting so
without further Ado vinnie2 brings to
you all the things dangerous and
diabolical in this video of top 10
one-piece villain Showcases of power
foreign
number 10 is a fight of cataclysmic
proportions between the shichibukai sir
crocodile and Luffy in the alabaster Ark
[Music]
[Applause]
the mysterious Walnut is the first major
antagonist in the series and the only
one to completely defeat Luffy not once
but twice innately cunning crocodile can
be set to be on par with Don Quixote
dofamingo both having masterminded the
collapse of entire countries the devil
fruit user crocodile is a sandman
capable of manipulating sandstorms to
devastating effect pitched against his
impressive repertoire of equally cruel
and sadistic techniques Luffy is left
impaled once dehydrated once and
poisoned as well and if not for Pure
dumb luck isaga would surely have been a
short one way before the time skip
without the knowledge of haki this
memorable Jewel had us hooked for the
overwhelming power displayed by
crocodile and the insane tenacity shown
by Luffy an important master in our
hero's journey this battle brings Straw
Hat Luffy to the Forefront in the eyes
of the world government and the pirate
world
foreign
God proceeds your name he says it all
and number nine is none other than the
god of lightning NL himself wiping the
floor with four strong contenders and
Nico Robin of the straw hat Pirates
former God gone fall and Sandy and War
real wiper
the four unlikely allies are the last
one standing in a wicked Survival game
orchestrated by NL who's the embodiment
of arrogance itself despite showing
righteous anger and fight the four are
easily defeated by their Supreme Nemesis
relatively early in the series this is
our first look at observation hockey
which when used in combination with his
insanely overpowered lightning makes NL
an unbeatable adversary to top it off a
prerequisite for being a God would
probably be immortality and NL proves to
be exactly that when he jump starts his
heart with his lightning after suffering
near fatal damage from a reject dial
attack it's difficult to name a more
unassailable adversary and NL is just
that
foreign
as luminous as God NL is the next
villain is Darkness incarnate in the A
spot Marshall D teach AKA Blackbeard
devours an entire town on banaro island
with his creepy power
[Music]
[Applause]
a more hateful villain is difficult to
imagine but Blackbeard must Trump the
worst having been part of the Whitebeard
Pirates one would expect him to have a
shred of a conscience however that would
be a tall order after killing a comrade
over a devil fruit and escaping the
unscrupulous villain decimates a whole
town to give a demonstration of his
stolen powers to his former Commander
Port gas D Ace the Insidious dark dark
fruit which is considered to be the most
evil is a perfect match for this
fiendish pirate and what follows next is
much more horrifying the inevitable
execution of Ace and the summit war of
marineford triggered by this ghastly
Jewel propels Blackbeard to the very top
of the list of arch enemies in the
one-piece Saga and we wait with baited
breath to see Justice served
[Applause]
up next at number seven is the
unfathomable barthora mukuma appearing
at the end of the Thriller bark Arc
[Music]
[Applause]
despite being a founding member of the
Revolutionary Army Kumar was nonetheless
seen as a villain because of his
affiliation with the world government on
orders to exterminate the straw hat
Pirates right after they defeated Gekko
Moria in a bruising battle the warlord
makes a hell of an appearance before the
Ragged survivors in spite of his
honorable side Kumar decides to act upon
his orders having eaten the poor poor
fruit he's able to repel anything with
the paws on the palms of his hands as
cute as that might sound Guma creates a
powerful bomb by compressing air into a
small Porsche bubble the ursa's shock
and releasing it at the incapacitated
crowd before the time skip it was a
rarity to see such a massive destruction
the blast radius covers the entire
Island ship as well as a substantial
part of the ocean the effect is
stupefying and Kumar lives up to his
title of tyrant in this merciless attack
[Music]
foreign
flamingo a warlord of the sea former
Noble an underground broker who's
Unleashed A Reign of Terror in the
Kingdom of dressrosser
[Music]
foreign
is the cold-blooded Mastermind behind
the plight of the enslaved citizens with
a world government and the Marines
backing him when chaos erupts in the
country he decides to erase all evidence
of his nefarious activities and he does
it in the most sadistic manner Possible
having eaten the string string fruit
Duffy can manipulate razor sharp strings
and when the massive Birdcage descends
on the people the panic and fear is
palpable capable of trapping everything
aside as well as cutting off all
Communications to the outside world The
Birdcage is truly a slaughterhouse
making doffy a very dangerous man a
scale above Kumar's Ursa shock this
technique leaves no question of survival
the moment Duffy unleashes The Birdcage
will forever remain one of the most
barbaric acts in one piece history at
the halfway mark now is the glitzy
Marine Admiral kizaru casually strolling
in on a cannonball to apprehend the 11
supernovas at salvodi
foreign
part of the world government's greatest
military force gizaru comes across as an
easy going man lacking fellow Admiral
sakazuki's extremist views on piracy and
Al Gigi's moralistic side it follows his
own code of unclear justice but make no
mistake gizaru shows no mercy towards
Pirates basil Hawkins urogs x-ray can
scratch man up and take him on with
their ultimate techniques it's an
impressive display from the monster
rookies but the light human proves to be
indestructible kizaru is capable of
lightning fast speed and then they don't
stand a chance against his glint glint
through Powers imagine being kicked at
the speed of light and when he stands
above roronoir Zorro's broken body the
straw hats can only look on horror
struck and helpless an indication of the
level of power to be expected in the new
world gizaru serves as a terrible Omen
for the young Pirates
hmm
making an appearance to get a number
four is the loathsome Blackbeard
[Music]
he may come across as a complete monster
in Troublemaker but every movie makes is
calculated and that's exactly how he
steals the source of whitebeard's
earthquake creating power the Tremor
Tremor fruit to form a diabolical duo
with his own dark dark fruit as he
unveils the two deadly Powers at
marineford we see how well the scheme of
capturing Ace fans the Flames of the war
between Whitebeard and the Marines
leading to the former's eventual death a
mysterious character ever since his
meeting with Luffy in Jaya Blackbeard's
exact motives are still a puzzle but his
meteorite rise to power from a
little-known pirate to warlord and then
to an emperor it's nothing short of
amazing when the mighty Marine
headquarters is raised to the ground and
ocean and Sky torn apart the entire
world watches aghast the final battle
between Luffy and the devil Blackbeard
will be something to watch out for stay
tuned for that
oh
come on
top three yonko big mom confronts you
Stars kid and killer Atop The Skull Dome
aided by her lightly special homie Hira
come on
Furious a kid for separating her from a
homies and dropping her to the Sea most
unceremoniously big mom resurfaces with
an ax to grind prompted by Prometheus to
replace the clumsy Zeus big mom creates
Hira feeding her a fragment of her own
soul it's Eerie yet heartwarming to see
her address the homies like children
having been semi-conscious throughout
the whole cake island arc we finally see
her shine alongside kaido in wano unlike
the other yonkos though big mom's a
little crazy which makes her
unpredictable and therefore much much
more dangerous on spying kid and killer
she immediately uses hero to dispatch
them with a lightning bolt the two
Escape but a gaping bowling kaido's
castle wall is left as testimony to her
raw destructive force with a fight
against kids still ongoing big mom lends
her own color to the series and makes it
that much more thrilling
onto the runners-up spot now and it's
none other than the honor bound
Charlotte katakuri sweet general of the
big mom Pirates
[Applause]
come on facing Luffy in the final Clash
after the disastrous tea party on whole
cake Island this is a haki Fiasco that
you don't want to miss katakuri is
proficient in all three types of haki
but when it comes to Observation haki he
easily outclasses Luffy by a league the
gentle monster can counter any attack
even if it's imbued with Armament hockey
and with his devil fruit powers that are
strikingly similar to Luffy's he can
mimic his foes every move and counter
with a larger stronger version in
contrast with Luffy's fight against
Duffy katakuri is more Relentless
however for a breakthrough in Luffy's
own powers the sweet General provides a
much-needed spur in a long fight lasting
over 10 hours garthakori stands as a
reminder about the increasingly
difficult challenges ahead of Luffy one
of which would be katakuri's mother big
mom
foreign
punch take out of Luffy in the ongoing
wano Arc
with an introduction like no other kaido
gets her attention from the get-go dead
drunk he soars across the sky in his
Dragon form and blasts an entire
mountain in half the Brash Luffy does
manage to bring the Azure Dragon
crashing down only to sober him up
having fought Warlords and the powerful
God that Gori before the Brash up star
greatly underestimates kaido claiming
that he'll put an end to him immediately
however the yawning Gap in power between
the two men becomes very apparent when
kaida releases a forbidding Aura of
conquerors haki and knocks out Luffy in
his gear fourth form with a single blow
whatever victories Luffy may have
garnered in the past kaido's a different
game altogether alcohol from a single
hit this is a humiliating exit for a
tenacious fighter like Luffy though
we're all counting on a strong combat
from the rubber man but as of now with
the battle still raging kaido's menacing
reputation endures but for how long well
that's the million dollar question
foreign
and that brings us to the end of the top
10 one-piece villain Showcases of power
from the downright nasty to the
conflicted from the gentleman to the
Beast I hope you enjoyed our selection
if you missed any do leave your
suggestions in the comments below if you
enjoyed our video and would like to
watch more then please like And
subscribe stay tuned for the next video